- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(upbeat techno music)
- Welcome everyone to
Extraordinary Variations
of the Human Mind:
Lessons from Anthropogeny.
This meeting is co-sponsored
by two organizations.
This is our first attempt.
It's our first effort at
bringing together these two.
One of the groups is called CARTA
which is the Center for Academic Research
and Training in Anthropogeny
and the other group is The Kavli Institute
here in San Diego, Institute
for Brain and Mind.
So CARTA is a
transdisciplinary collaboration
between UCSD and the Salk Institute
with the mission and interest
to explore and explain
the origins of the human phenomenon.
I'm happy to co-direct this
with Ajit Varki and Margaret Schoeninger
and our associate director Pascal Gagneux.
The Kavli Institute has a
slightly different focus
focusing primarily on the brain
and in particular also an
interdisciplinary approach
seeking to understand
the origins of evolution,
mechanisms of human cognition.
So you can see how this title
of this topic blends well
between our two organizations
and I co-direct that with Nick
Spitzer and Ralph Greenspan.
So the oldest questions
for humans, of humans,
are who are we, what are we doing here,
where do we come from,
how did we get here,
and where are we going?
Some of these questions are
really unapproachable right now.
We just don't have methods
or really the intellectual
hardware to deal with them,
but we can address some of them
like where did we come from
and how did we get here and
that's the focus of our effort.
We reinvented or remade
this term anthropogeny
which is explaining origins of humans
as a way of focusing on
this last period of time
as humans emerged as a species.
So where did we come from
and how did we get there?
Anthropogeny, as we see it,
is really an interdisciplinary field.
We have people from humanities,
biological sciences,
engineering, physical sciences,
and as you look at our website,
you can see a list of the
topics that we've sponsored
over the last 20 years
that cover the interaction
of a lot of these different disciplines.
We're particularly thankful
to the Mathers Charitable Foundation
headed by Howard Chester,
the executive director,
who sponsored CARTA for many years
and we hope will continue to do so.
Some of you may have heard
of The Kavli Foundation.
It's dedicated to advancing
science in a more general way
in ways that promote the
benefits of humanity,
promoting public understanding
of science research.
They have multiple areas of emphasis
including nanoscience and astrophysics
and a strong emphasis on neuroscience
and our community here
fosters this interest in neuroscience.
The leadership acknowledge
Miyoung Chun and Robert Conn
who are the directors and
founders of the foundation.
I wanna give a special
thanks to Annette Merle-Smith
who for her generous support
for the Graduate
Specialization in Anthropogeny.
We have a graduate-level
supplemental major at UCSD.
We have coursework and it's
really quite a fun activity
and many of them are scattered
throughout the audience today.
James Handelman had been
the director for CARTA
and was the founding support for us
through the Mathers Foundation
and he had an untimely death recently
and we've put together
a James Handelman Memorial Symposium Fund
to perpetuate the support of
this series of talks and CARTA
and here are some of
the names of the people
that have put forth some
funding to help support us.
We also have individual support
that supplements our activities
and I'm just putting these
names up to acknowledge them
and thank them very much
for their continued support
on an annual basis for our activities
to allow us to continue
with these presentations.
Finally, I'd like to give a special thanks
to the CARTA staff and the KIBM Staff
for whom the organization
of these meetings
could not happen without.
We also have terrific
support from UCSD-TV,
Rich and Matt and Steve and Marci.
And finally, Kent and Michael
from Salk Media Services
who help throughout this time.
And finally, Davis Svoboda
for a really wonderful
guitar interlude at the beginning.
George, George.
(audience applause)
(upbeat techno music)